This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A warning before we start today's show, this episode includes accounts of sexual assault and may not be suitable for all listeners. In 2016, Maya Armanson sat down at her laptop to write a Facebook post. It was about a famous playwright, Israel Horowitz. She accused him of serious sexual misconduct. He put this anger in me that I didn't have before and that wasn't going away and I couldn't let it rest.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。在节目开始前有一个警告，本期节目包含性侵犯的叙述，可能不适合所有听众。2016年，Maya Armanson坐在笔记本电脑前写了一篇Facebook帖子。内容是关于一位著名的剧作家Israel Horowitz。她指控他有严重的性不当行为。他激起了我内心从未有过的愤怒，这种愤怒挥之不去，我无法让它平息。
Within months, other women stepped forward with similar stories. But yeah, no, he just locked the door and then he... Nobody was there and it was... And then he just... I never thought it would go this far. I went to the managing director and said I was quitting. The theater world was quick to censure the playwright. Several companies dropped productions of his plays. He quickly resigned from the board of the theater company
几个月内，其他女性也站出来讲述了类似的故事。但是，是的，不，他只是锁上了门，然后他……没人在这儿，而且是……然后他只是……我从没想过事情会发展到这一步。我去找总经理说我要辞职。戏剧界很快谴责了这位剧作家。几家公司取消了他剧作的演出。他很快辞去了剧团董事会的职务，
that he'd found it. Israel Horowitz was disgraced. His career in tatters. But here's the twist. Twenty-four years earlier, another group of women had made nearly identical accusations, and nothing happened. This week on Hidden Brain, we ask, why now? Why have so many women stepped forward to make accusations about sexual harassment
他创立的那个剧团。Israel Horowitz名誉扫地。他的事业支离破碎。但转折点在这里。二十四年前，另一群女性曾提出几乎相同的指控，但什么也没发生。本周在Hidden Brain，我们问，为什么是现在？为什么这么多女性站出来指控性骚扰
and assault, and why is the world finally taking them seriously? In the mid-1980s, Jocelyn Minehart was a high school student in New York City. She was known for her sense of humor and her oversized vintage clothes. She was dating Adam Horowitz, a teenage musician from the band The Beastie Boys. I went out with him from the time I was 15 to 17. After high school, Jocelyn enrolled at New York University to pursue a degree in dramatic writing. One day, in 1989, she got a call. It was Adam's father,
和性侵犯，为什么世界终于开始认真对待她们了？20世纪80年代中期，Jocelyn Minehart是纽约市的一名高中生。她以幽默感和超大号的复古服装而闻名。她当时正在和Adam Horowitz约会，他是Beastie Boys乐队的一名少年音乐家。我从15岁到17岁一直和他交往。高中毕业后，Jocelyn进入纽约大学攻读戏剧写作学位。1989年的一天，她接到了一个电话。是Adam的父亲，
the 49-year-old playwright, Israel Horvitz. Israel was like, I have a play and two tickets, you know, come to see it. I was like, this is weird. And I don't even think before then I'd seen any of his plays. Like, I just had no relation. He was just like my boyfriends father. Jocelyn went to see the play with her new boyfriend. Sometime later she says, Israel invited her to have coffee. She told him she was studying at NYU. And then, you know, he was like, oh you're in dramatic writing school that silly you should be like just writing. And then, Israel made Jocelyn an incredible offer.
49岁的剧作家Israel Horowitz。Israel说，我有一部戏和两张票，你知道，来看看吧。我想，这太奇怪了。而且在那之前，我想我甚至没看过他的任何戏。就像，我跟他没有任何关系。他只是我男朋友的父亲。Jocelyn和她的新男友去看了那部戏。后来她说，Israel邀请她去喝咖啡。她告诉他她正在纽约大学学习。然后，你知道，他说，哦，你在戏剧写作学校，那太傻了，你应该直接写作。然后，Israel向Jocelyn提出了一个令人难以置信的提议。
He asked if she'd like to work the summer at his theater in Gloucester, Massachusetts. He created a position for me where he was like, you can come up and be like the Samuel Beckett Fellow. A playwriting fellowship at a professional theater company. And get a stipend? It was unreal, a huge break for a 19-year-old student. Jocelyn says to top it all, he told her he would take her under his wing, teacher his craft, so you went.
他问她愿不愿意夏天去他在马萨诸塞州格洛斯特的剧院工作。他为我创造了一个职位，他说，你可以过来担任Samuel Beckett研究员。一家专业剧团的剧本创作奖学金。还有津贴？这太不真实了，对一个19岁的学生来说是一个巨大的机会。Jocelyn说最重要的是，他告诉她他会把她带在身边，教她手艺，所以你就去了。
Yeah. Of course she went. It was like a big heavy door was being thrown open. Beyond lay endless possibility. It was really the first time I was going to be away from home, like even summer camp up till then it had been like two weeks, you know. I remember not knowing how to feed myself, like I ate a lot of cereal that summer and candy bars so.
是的。她当然去了。就像一扇沉重的大门被打开了。门后是无限的可能性。那真的是我第一次离家，甚至在那之前的夏令营也只有两周，你知道。我记得不知道怎么照顾自己，那个夏天我吃了很多麦片和糖果棒。
At the end of May, Jocelyn packed her stuff and headed up to the blue collar fishing town of Gloucester. The theatre company had rented a room for her. With this really cool senior citizen fisherman's wife who was really awesome. Jocelyn started settling in. The next day... Israel showed up and was like hop in my car and we'll drive up to my house. I remember so clearly because it was a really foggy day, so just everything about it was just creepy and it wasn't late in the evening,
五月底，Jocelyn收拾好行李，前往格洛斯特这个蓝领渔镇。剧团为她租了一个房间。和一个非常酷的资深渔民的妻子住在一起，她真的很棒。Jocelyn开始安顿下来。第二天……Israel出现了，说跳上我的车，我们开车去我家。我记得非常清楚，因为那天雾很大，所以关于它的一切都让人毛骨悚然，而且当时并不晚，
it was just like dinner time. They drove through the fog to Israel's house. They went inside. And that door, the one she thought would lead to endless possibility Slamshot We just locked the door and then immediately like stuck his tongue down my mouth and I remember just feeling so trapped And I remember looking out the window and thinking can I run? If I had left, you know, would anybody
只是晚饭时间。他们穿过浓雾开车去Israel的家。他们进去了。而那扇她以为会通向无限可能的大门，砰地关上了。我们刚锁上门，他立刻就把舌头伸进我的嘴里，我记得当时感觉被困住了。我记得看着窗外想，我能跑吗？如果我离开了，你知道，会有人
Help me and wouldn't I look ridiculous because I'd walked into this house and Israel could just say like, oh she's mentally unstable or whatever you know. Remember this was before cell phones, ubers and Google maps. Instead of running, Jocelyn froze. I felt like I was in shock. Like it was so shocking. It was so shocking. This is my my ex-boyfriends father, you know? Like I Laugh like but then I said I am not here for this. I don't want to do this and He said this is inevitable. This was inevitable and And I realized that he wasn't viewing it. And I started to cry.
帮我吗？而且我看起来不是很可笑吗，因为我走进了这所房子，而Israel可以随便说，哦，她精神不稳定之类的，你知道。记住，那是在手机、优步和谷歌地图出现之前。Jocelyn没有跑，而是僵住了。我觉得我处于休克状态。这太令人震惊了。这是我前男友的父亲，你知道吗？我笑，但后来我说我不是为了这个来的。我不想做这个，他说这是不可避免的。这是不可避免的，我意识到他并没有把它看作……我开始哭泣。
And I think clearly you shouldn't have sex with somebody unless they're crying for joy. And so I do feel like on some level he knew what he was doing. But yeah, he led me upstairs and I was crying. And remember, it's kind of seeing it from an aerial perspective. While I wasn't grabbed by my hair and dragged through a park in the middle of the night, could I describe it as rape? Like, could I, you know, because I wasn't screaming and saying no, no, no, no, was that rape?
我认为很明显，除非对方是喜极而泣，否则你不应该和某人发生性关系。所以我确实觉得在某种程度上他知道自己在做什么。但是是的，他带我上楼，我当时在哭。记住，这就像是从空中视角看它。虽然我没有被抓住头发在半夜被拖过公园，但我能把它描述为强奸吗？就像，我能吗，你知道，因为我没有尖叫着说不，不，不，不，那是强奸吗？
Jocelyn didn't say a word to anyone. I just thought, if I tell people and deal with this, I will have to go home and lose this opportunity. And it felt I would have to deal with all this shame and embarrassment over what happened because didn't I know that this would happen. So it just seemed wiser to just soldier on. So that's what she did. In the weeks that followed, Jarslyn tried to avoid Israel's advances. Sometimes she succeeded, but she says not always. One of the times was in the room I was staying where I also had my computer set up to write
Jocelyn没有对任何人说一个字。我只是想，如果我告诉别人并处理这件事，我就必须回家，失去这个机会。我觉得我必须处理因为发生的事情而带来的所有羞耻和尴尬，因为难道我不知道会发生这种事吗？所以继续前进似乎更明智。于是她就这样做了。在接下来的几周里，Jocelyn试图避开Israel的追求。有时她成功了，但她说并不总是这样。其中一次是在我住的房间里，我也在那里设置了电脑来写作，
and he came over to help me with my play and then put the moves on me. And it was sort of like we have to have sex before I'm going to sit down and help you with your play. And that's exactly what happened. The other time, he was like, oh, my office in town is a mess. Like, come help me clean it up. And then we're there. So it was essentially like if he was alone with me in a place other than the theater and other than his house, which now had his kids and his twins and his nanny, like if he could get me into a place and he was able to do that twice.
他过来帮我写剧本，然后对我动手动脚。这就像是我们必须先发生性关系，他才会坐下来帮我写剧本。事情就是这样发生的。另一次，他说，哦，我在镇上的办公室一团糟。来帮我清理一下。然后我们就到了那里。所以本质上，如果他在剧院和他家以外的地方和我单独在一起，而他家现在有他的孩子、双胞胎和保姆，如果他能把我带到一个地方，他就能做到，他确实做到了两次。
And both times I didn't fight him off. And I did feel like I had made that decision. Like I'm just not going to tell anyone ever. And I don't want to ruin this opportunity. So, you know, I thought I remember thinking at that time that you could absolutely forget things. I was like, I'm going to block this, I'm not going to think about it and I'll be fine. You know, like I didn't understand that that's not how the brain works. For Jocelyn, the summer became something to endure.
两次我都没有反抗。我确实觉得我做出了那个决定。就像我永远不会告诉任何人。我不想毁掉这个机会。所以，你知道，我记得当时想，你绝对可以忘记一些事情。我想，我要屏蔽它，我不会去想它，我会没事的。你知道，我不明白大脑不是那样工作的。对Jocelyn来说，那个夏天变成了一种忍受。
It was all made worse by the fact that the Glastor Stage Company was producing a searing play about the trauma of rape. It was called the Widows Blind Date. The playwright, Israel Horowitz. The play tells a story of Margi, a woman in her 30s. Back when she was 17, Margi was gang raped by seven young men, including her high school classmates, George and Archie. She's now returned to her hometown in Massachusetts to confront those two men. Much of the play depicts a world where men casually demean women. In one scene, Margi describes what it feels like to be endlessly
更糟糕的是，格洛斯特舞台公司正在制作一部关于强奸创伤的尖锐剧作。剧名叫《寡妇的盲约》。剧作家是Israel Horowitz。这部戏讲述了30多岁的Margi的故事。17岁时，Margi被七个年轻人轮奸，其中包括她的高中同学George和Archie。她现在回到了马萨诸塞州的家乡去面对那两个人。剧中的大部分内容描绘了一个男人随意贬低女性的世界。在一个场景中，Margi描述了被男人无休止地
objectified by men. She counts off the many slang terms used to describe women's breasts and voices her exhaustion and exasperation at being groped. We had an actor perform an excerpt from the play, again, a warning that this section involves language that may not be appropriate for all listeners. You're thinking it over, Archie and George, I will gladly give my breasts over to you for whatever purpose you choose. George, you would wear them on the odd days Archie on the events and I'd be free to get back to work, to get back to sleep at night, to end the constant and unrelenting fondling.
物化是什么感觉。她数落了许多用来描述女性乳房的俚语，并表达了她对被猥亵的疲惫和愤怒。我们请了一位演员表演了剧中的一段摘录，再次警告，这一部分涉及的语言可能不适合所有听众。你在考虑这件事，Archie和George，我会很乐意把我的乳房交给你们，用于你们选择的任何目的。George，你在单数日子戴着它们，Archie在双数日子，我就能自由地回去工作，晚上回去睡觉，结束那持续不断且无情的抚摸。
I've saw that play like 500 times because that was the play that was being produced the summer I was there, like the worst summer of my life. And so it was really, no, it's just so complicated and ridiculous because I basically had to watch a play about a woman who was raped confronting her rapist. And, no, and that's what part of, you know, I remember Israel saying to me at one point, like, can you imagine hurting somebody, like, what that would do, like, how ridiculous that is?
我看了那部戏大约500次，因为那是我在那里那个夏天制作的戏，那是我一生中最糟糕的夏天。所以这真的很……不，这太复杂和荒谬了，因为我基本上不得不看一部关于一个被强奸的女人面对强奸犯的戏。而且，不，这就是其中的一部分，你知道，我记得Israel有一次对我说，你能想象伤害某人吗，那会造成什么后果，这有多荒谬？
And I was just like, you have hurt me. Like, it just was such a mind-bender. We repeatedly reached out to Israel Horowitz via phone, email and letters. We asked him about the allegations that Jocelyn and other women have made against him and the apparent contradiction between the message of his play and his alleged behavior. He declined an interview, saying, I'm recovering from two major cancer surgeries. My play, The Widow's Blind Date, states clearly my feeling about sexual violence against women, which I find to be a warrant and intolerable.
我当时就想，你伤害了我。这真是一个让人精神错乱的事情。我们多次通过电话、电子邮件和信件联系Israel Horowitz。我们问他关于Jocelyn和其他女性对他提出的指控，以及他的剧作信息与他被指控的行为之间明显的矛盾。他拒绝接受采访，说，我正在从两次重大癌症手术中恢复。我的剧作《寡妇的盲约》清楚地表达了我对针对女性的性暴力的感受，我认为这是令人发指且不可容忍的。
When we come back, we look at the psychology of when people stay silent and when they speak up. You're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. People often stay silent even when they want to speak up. We may think something in private, but say nothing in public. This happens to individuals who've suffered abuse. This happens with the entire nations. Duke University political scientist Timur Koran says that people pay close attention to
回来后，我们将探讨人们保持沉默和挺身而出时的心理。你正在收听Hidden Brain。这是NPR。这是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。人们即使在想说话时也经常保持沉默。我们可能私下里想些什么，但在公开场合却什么也不说。这种情况发生在遭受虐待的个人身上。这种情况也发生在整个国家。杜克大学政治学家Timur Kuran说，人们密切关注
public opinion and figure out that sometimes it's wiser to shut up. The punishments for expressing a controversial view cover a wide range. At one extreme, there can be a knock on your door at 4 o'clock in the morning and you can be dragged to prison, you can be taken to a concentration camp. There are societies where that happens, but there are much milder forms of punishment. You can be ostracized from a community, you can be rebuked, your career can be placed in danger. And so people say one thing publicly, and believe another thing privately.
公众舆论，并意识到有时闭嘴更明智。表达有争议观点的惩罚范围很广。在一个极端，你可能会在凌晨4点被敲门，被拖进监狱，被送进集中营。有些社会确实会发生这种情况，但也有更温和的惩罚形式。你可能会被社区排斥，你可能会受到谴责，你的职业生涯可能会受到威胁。所以人们公开说一套，私下里却相信另一套。
To more Quran calls this preference falsification. When our views clash with what we perceive to be the prevailing currents, we realize it's dangerous to openly express ourselves. A good example is East Germany during Soviet control. For decades communism survived by making the populations it ruled afraid to express opposition to the principles of communism and express opposition to the dictatorships that were running the Soviet block countries. The silence around Harvey Weinstein's sexual misconduct operated in the same way. It was an open secret for decades we've learned
Timur Kuran称之为偏好伪装。当我们的观点与我们所感知的普遍潮流相冲突时，我们意识到公开表达自己是危险的。一个很好的例子是苏联控制下的东德。几十年来，共产主义通过让它统治的人民害怕表达对共产主义原则的反对，以及表达对统治苏联集团国家的独裁政权的反对而生存下来。围绕Harvey Weinstein性不当行为的沉默也是以同样的方式运作的。我们了解到，几十年来这是一个公开的秘密，
in Hollywood and in circles that Harvey Weinstein traveled in that he was a predator of young women, but also that if anybody called them out on this, he would ruin their careers. There are ways to talk about our secrets, ways to voice our truths while maintaining plausible plausible deniability. The best way, humor. This is from the sitcom 30 Rock. Don't do it, J-mo. You don't want to mess with weird hours. Oh please, I'm not afraid of anyone in show business. I turned down intercourse with Harvey Weinstein on no less than three occasions out of five. And several years ago, at an Oscar nomination ceremony, Seth McFarlane told this joke. The 2012 nominee is for Best Performance by an Actress in a Supporting Roll, R. Sally
在好莱坞和Harvey Weinstein出入的圈子里，他是一个年轻女性的掠夺者，但也知道如果有人揭露这一点，他会毁掉他们的职业生涯。有一些方法可以谈论我们的秘密，在保持合理推诿的同时表达我们的真相。最好的方法是幽默。这是来自情景喜剧《我为喜剧狂》。别那样做，J-mo。你不想惹上奇怪的时间。哦，拜托，我不怕演艺界的任何人。我至少有三次拒绝了Harvey Weinstein的性要求。几年前，在奥斯卡提名仪式上，Seth McFarlane讲了这个笑话。2012年最佳女配角提名是，R. Sally
Field in Lincoln and Halfaway in Les Miserables. Jackie Weaver in Silver Lining's Playbook. Helen Hunt in the Sessions and Amy Adams in the master. Congratulations, you five ladies no longer have to pretend to be attracted to Harvey Weinstein. Did you hear that laughter? Everyone got it. To more says when the Soviet Union tightly controlled East Germany, jokes were common there too. Jokes about the aging Soviet leaders, jokes about how inefficient the Soviet economy was, jokes about how hollow Marxism was, but when the information about all of these deficiencies of the system were put in jokes. The person telling the joke did not have to take ownership of the claims, where they
Field在《林肯》中，Anne Hathaway在《悲惨世界》中。Jacki Weaver在《乌云背后的幸福线》中。Helen Hunt在《亲密治疗》中，Amy Adams在《大师》中。恭喜你们五位女士，不再需要假装被Harvey Weinstein吸引了。你听到那笑声了吗？每个人都听懂了。Timur说，当苏联严密控制东德时，那里的笑话也很普遍。关于年迈苏联领导人的笑话，关于苏联经济效率低下的笑话，关于马克思主义有多空洞的笑话，但当关于系统所有这些缺陷的信息被放入笑话中时。讲笑话的人不必对这些主张负责，他们
drew the line is with writing an article that would go into a newspaper that would put in words backed up by facts, the deficiencies of the system that you were joking about. There is power in the written word. Sometimes it takes a news article to turn whispered injustices into public outrage. But this is where the story of Israel Horowitz gets complicated. Preference falsification was certainly at play in keeping women like Jocelyn Minehart silent. But it doesn't explain everything. In 1993, an envelope showed up in a Boston newsroom in the mailbox of a theatre critic.
划清界限的地方是写一篇会进入报纸的文章，用事实支持的话语写出你正在开玩笑的系统缺陷。文字是有力量的。有时需要一篇新闻文章才能将耳语中的不公正转化为公众的愤怒。但这就是Israel Horowitz的故事变得复杂的地方。偏好伪装确实在让像Jocelyn Minehart这样的女性保持沉默方面发挥了作用。但这并不能解释一切。1993年，一个信封出现在波士顿新闻编辑室一位戏剧评论家的邮箱里。
They sort of plain white envelope addressed to me. This is Bill Marx. He now teaches at Boston University. But back in the early 90s, he was writing for the Boston Phoenix. Which is part of what was then a very proud tradition of alternative presses. Bill wrote theatre reviews. So when he tore up in the envelope in his mailbox, he was expecting what he usually received, a hate note from an angry actor.
那是一个寄给我的普通白色信封。这是Bill Marx。他现在在波士顿大学任教。但在90年代初，他为《波士顿凤凰报》撰稿。这是当时非常自豪的另类媒体传统的一部分。Bill写戏剧评论。所以当他撕开邮箱里的信封时，他期待的是他通常收到的东西，一封来自愤怒演员的仇恨信。
That is not what he found. This was a different kind of note. And it essentially was a plea from an anonymous woman at the Gloucester Stage Company saying that they were being molested, that they were being sexually harassed by the artistic director that they had. I remember that they in the note mentioned that they created a buddy system to protect each other and they wanted some help. And it was really to me when I read it, it was a cry for help. Bill was stunned.
那不是他发现的东西。这是一封不同类型的信。它本质上是格洛斯特舞台公司一位匿名女性的恳求，说她们正在被猥亵，她们正在被她们拥有的艺术总监性骚扰。我记得她们在信中提到她们建立了一个伙伴系统来互相保护，她们想要一些帮助。对我来说，当我读到它时，那是一种求救信号。Bill惊呆了。
He wasn't really a reporter, let alone an investigative reporter. And yet he says, it felt like he'd been singled out to do something, like he was being tested. I wanted to check it out. I didn't immediately go, oh, this must be true, but I felt, well, I'm hearing this note. It sounded authentic to me, at least enough to where I wanted to start going out and talking to the actresses to see whether it was true or not.
他并不是真正的记者，更不用说调查记者了。然而他说，感觉就像他被选中去做某事，就像他正在接受考验。我想核实一下。我没有立刻说，哦，这一定是真的，但我感觉，好吧，我听到了这封信。它听起来很真实，至少足以让我开始走出去和女演员们交谈，看看它是否属实。
He started reaching out to women he knew had worked at the Gloucester Stage Company. Sometimes I would have to call two or three times. At times they were reluctant. They will say, well, I'd like to talk but I can't talk now or let me think about this. But slowly, women began to tell him their stories. I mean, there was a tremendous amount of feeling, particularly among the actresses, that if this came out, they would not get jobs. They'd be labeled as being very difficult to work with, so that they were putting a lot on the line when they were doing this.
他开始联系他知道在格洛斯特舞台公司工作过的女性。有时我不得不打两三次电话。有时她们很勉强。她们会说，好吧，我想谈谈，但我现在不能谈，或者让我考虑一下。但慢慢地，女性开始告诉他她们的故事。我的意思是，有一种巨大的感觉，特别是在女演员中，如果这件事传出去，她们将无法获得工作。她们会被贴上非常难合作的标签，所以她们在做这件事时冒了很大的风险。
It's important to note that at this time, Israel Horowitz was a big fish in a small pond. He was an internationally known playwright, running a powerhouse theater in an old, gritty, fishing town. He had a bit of celebrity star power and used to drive around Gloucester in a little sports car with a license plate that had author in capital letters and he used to wear a sort of beret. Laura Crook remembers that vanity plate.
值得注意的是，在那个时候，Israel Horowitz在小池塘里是一条大鱼。他是一位国际知名的剧作家，在一个古老、坚韧的渔镇经营着一家强大的剧院。他有一点名人的明星力量，过去常开着一辆带有作者大写字母车牌的小跑车在格洛斯特转悠，他过去常戴着一种贝雷帽。Laura Crook记得那个虚荣车牌。
She's one of the women who reached out to Bill with a story to share. They agreed to meet in his apartment. We went in, sat down, he gave me a glass of water, and had his little tape recorder. And he said, you know, we'll start when you're ready. In the summer of 1989, she set she attended the Gloucester Stage Company's production of the Widows Blind Date. She told Bill she fell in love with a small black box theater and jumped at an opportunity to audition for Israel the following year. And I went in and I think I either asked him if he would know what he wanted or he said you know okay do the monologue
她是联系Bill分享故事的女性之一。他们同意在他的公寓见面。我们进去，坐下，他给了我一杯水，拿着他的小录音机。他说，你知道，你准备好了我们就开始。1989年夏天，她参加了格洛斯特舞台公司的《寡妇的盲约》制作。她告诉Bill她爱上了那个黑色小剧场，并抓住了第二年为Israel试镜的机会。我进去了，我想要么我问他他想要什么，要么他说你知道好吧，做那个独白，
and I want you to cry three times and I said okay and I did the monologue and I cried three times. And I said, okay. And I did the monologue and I cried three times. And then a couple days later they asked me if I would understudy. And I said, yes, absolutely. But even before she started the new gig, a friend in the Boston Theatre World told her, hey, try not to be alone with him. And I said, uh, okay. You know, that's going to be... she's like, just trying not to be alone with him. Once she got to Gloucester, another actress issued the very same warning. Trying not to be alone with him.
我想要你哭三次，我说好吧，我做了独白，我哭了三次。我说，好吧。我做了独白，我哭了三次。然后几天后他们问我是否愿意做替补。我说，是的，绝对愿意。但即使在她开始这份新工作之前，波士顿戏剧界的一位朋友就告诉她，嘿，尽量不要和他单独在一起。我说，呃，好吧。你知道，那会……她说，只是尽量不要和他单独在一起。一旦她到了格洛斯特，另一位女演员发出了同样的警告。尽量不要和他单独在一起。
Rehearsals began. One day, as other actors worked on a scene, Israel called Laura over. And, uh, and Israel said, hey, why don't we go in the green room so we can work on your monologue? And I said, okay, because that's totally normal. There's nothing at all that's absolutely normal to do. So we went into the green room and we sat down on the couch
排练开始了。有一天，当其他演员在排练一个场景时，Israel叫Laura过去。然后，Israel说，嘿，我们为什么不去休息室，这样我们就可以练习你的独白了？我说，好吧，因为这完全正常。没有什么绝对不正常的事情。所以我们走进休息室，坐在沙发上，
and I said, so let's just read through the monologue and I started to read through it. And then he just was on me. And he had his tongue in my mouth and his hand on my shirt. And I jumped up and made a joke. I said, that's not in the script. He came at me again and I pushed him away and I don't know what I said then. I think it's a lot of blood brushes to your ears and situations like that and just kind of figure out how the hell they get out of there.
我说，那我们就读一遍独白，我开始读它。然后他就在我身上了。他的舌头在我的嘴里，他的手在我的衬衫上。我跳起来开了一个玩笑。我说，那不在剧本里。他又向我扑来，我把他推开，我不知道我当时说了什么。我想在那种情况下，很多血涌向你的耳朵，你只是想弄清楚到底该怎么从那里逃出来。
Laura says she wasn't the only one at the theater fending off Israel's advances. So she worked out a body system with another woman. Israel didn't like lipstick. It didn't like red lipstick. And so we had a tube of lipstick. I had it in my box, my dressing table. So we would always put on lipstick when he was around. Another time, Israel asked Laura to come into the shop to hand her some notes.
Laura说她不是剧院里唯一一个抵挡Israel追求的人。所以她和另一位女性制定了一个伙伴系统。Israel不喜欢口红。他不喜欢红色口红。所以我们有一管口红。我把它放在我的盒子里，我的梳妆台上。所以当他在附近时，我们总是会涂上口红。另一次，Israel让Laura去车间给他递一些笔记。
Laura caught the eye of her friend. I mean, in true black comedy, she was the technical director, but she kept announcing that she was coming into the shop to get a tool of some sort of like, I'm going to get a hammer. And then she'd go that she was coming into the shop to get a tool of some sort of like, I'm going to get a hammer, and then she'd go in and she'd get the shop back and walk out, like she would not get what she was talking about. And then he would try to kiss me and then she would come back in and interrupt us again. It was a kind of job a person would want to quit as fast as possible.
Laura引起了她朋友的注意。我的意思是，在真正的黑色喜剧中，她是技术总监，但她一直宣布她要进车间去拿某种工具，就像，我要去拿一把锤子。然后她会去……她要进车间去拿某种工具，就像，我要去拿一把锤子，然后她会进去，她会把车间弄得乱七八糟然后走出来，就像她根本没拿她说的东西。然后他会试图亲吻我，然后她会再次进来打断我们。这是一种人会想尽快辞掉的工作。
And yet, when Laura was asked back for another summer of work, she said, yes. You know, I've been thinking a lot about that. A lot recently, but I think over the years, I think about it. I wanted to work. Like, there's just not a lot of work out there. I mean, it's a hard job, it's a hard career. And he wasn't always assaulting you. Sometimes you had these really great conversations about show business and theater and being creative and the art that we all make.
然而，当Laura被邀请回来再工作一个夏天时，她说，是的。你知道，我最近一直在想这件事。很多时候，我想过它。我想工作。就像，外面没有多少工作。我的意思是，这是一份艰苦的工作，这是一个艰苦的职业。而且他并不总是攻击你。有时你们会进行关于演艺、戏剧和创造力以及我们所有人创造的艺术的非常棒的对话。
And so I just wanted to believe otherwise. It's just trying to make sense of it so that you can live in this world. Bill Marks understood the dilemma, Laura and the other women faced. I mean, their careers were on, they felt, their careers were on the line that they would be labeled as difficult.
所以我只是想相信别的东西。这只是试图理解它，这样你就可以生活在这个世界上。Bill Marx理解Laura和其他女性面临的困境。我的意思是，她们的职业生涯，她们觉得，她们的职业生涯岌岌可危，她们会被贴上难相处的标签。
They'd be labeled as man haters. They'd be labeled as, you know, somehow making things up about Horvitz, who apparently was telling everyone that this is just part of his sort of, you know, theater slash Hollywood, kissy kissy, huggy, huggy demeanor. Two of the women told Bill that complained to the stage company's board of directors, but to their knowledge, nothing had been done. When Bill reached out to the board president, he was told the women's stories didn't fit the legal definition of sexual harassment.
她们会被贴上厌男者的标签。她们会被贴上，你知道，以某种方式编造关于Horowitz的事情的标签，他显然在告诉每个人这只是他那种，你知道，戏剧/好莱坞，亲亲抱抱的举止的一部分。其中两名女性告诉Bill，她们向剧团董事会投诉过，但据她们所知，什么也没做。当Bill联系董事会主席时，他被告知这些女性的故事不符合性骚扰的法律定义。
On August 6, 1993, the Boston Phoenix published Bill's article. It included the stories of six women. They chose to remain anonymous, but said they would identify themselves if the paper was sued. A week later, the Phoenix published a follow-up story after four more women came forward, three were Nannies who'd worked in Israel's house. To me, I absolutely proved what was going on, given the number of women and the activities.
1993年8月6日，《波士顿凤凰报》发表了Bill的文章。它包含了六名女性的故事。她们选择保持匿名，但表示如果报纸被起诉，她们会表明身份。一周后，在又有四名女性站出来后，凤凰报发表了一篇后续报道，其中三名是曾在Israel家里工作的保姆。对我来说，考虑到女性的数量和活动，我绝对证明了正在发生的事情。
Then, you know, when the second article came out and I was called, all the Nannis had called me and suddenly I had, you know, some other women contacting me, then I felt that A, I've opened the floodgates. Now they're definitely going to have to do something. How can they ignore this? But it was ignored. Officials at the theater recently said that in 1993, they conducted an investigation and crafted a new sexual harassment policy. The theater said Israel flatly denied the charges
然后，你知道，当第二篇文章出来时，我被叫到了，所有的保姆都给我打了电话，突然间我有了，你知道，其他一些女性联系我，那时我觉得A，我打开了闸门。现在她们肯定得做点什么了。她们怎么能忽视这一点？但它被忽视了。剧院官员最近表示，1993年，他们进行了调查并制定了新的性骚扰政策。剧院表示Israel断然否认了这些指控，
and that the women who spoke to Bill did not come forward to identify themselves. But in Bill's article, the board president is also quoted as characterizing the women as tightly wound. Laura Krook remembers being really angry and really sad. But mostly like, okay. That's it. Okay. I mean, we were two years out of Anita Hill, so we saw how that went. It wasn't much of a surprise.
而且那些与Bill交谈的女性并没有站出来表明身份。但在Bill的文章中，董事会主席也被引用将这些女性描述为神经质。Laura Crook记得当时非常生气和悲伤。但更多的是，好吧。就这样。好吧。我的意思是，我们距离Anita Hill事件已经两年了，所以我们看到了结果如何。这并不令人惊讶。
It was just... I hadn't thought about how much it hurt until now, until all that we surfacing again. What it is to be... to know you're telling the truth and to be summarily dismissed. Laura and Jocelyn's stories help us understand why the Me Too movement didn't take off 25 years ago. To more Quran would call it preference falsification. Princeton psychology professor Betsy Palak cites a complimentary idea known as social
这只是……直到现在，直到所有这些再次浮出水面，我才想到它有多痛。知道自己在说真话却被草率驳回是什么感觉。Laura和Jocelyn的故事帮助我们理解了为什么Me Too运动在25年前没有起飞。Timur Kuran会称之为偏好伪装。普林斯顿心理学教授Betsy Paluck引用了一个互补的观点，称为社会
proof. When people are deciding whether to step forward and say something, they look at what happened to others who stepped forward before them. It's social proof that it's most basic. We want to know, we wonder how we'll be treated if we step forward to blow the whistle on a certain kind of behavior, and we need sometimes to watch someone else do it and to see what realistically are the consequences. When Laura and other actors reveal their stories and found it made no difference, Other women received a clear message. Shut up. Stay silent.
证明。当人们决定是否要站出来说些什么时，他们会看看之前站出来的人发生了什么。这是最基本的社会证明。我们想知道，我们想知道如果我们站出来揭发某种行为会受到怎样的对待，我们需要有时看着别人这样做，看看现实中的后果是什么。当Laura和其他演员揭露她们的故事并发现没有任何改变时，其他女性收到了一个明确的信息。闭嘴。保持沉默。
Women, especially, used to watch other women report and maybe lose their jobs or just not be heard at all or be disparaged. So that is the kind of social proof that used to inform women's decisions about reporting sexual harassment. Another young woman said she met Israel Horowitz in 1994. Yana Misteki was in turning at a small theater in Paris where Israel was working. She says he tried to kiss her and once, tried to pull her into his bedroom. When Yana discovered Bill Mox's stories, She received social proof about what would happen
女性，特别是，过去常看着其他女性举报，也许失去了工作，或者根本没有被听到，或者被贬低。所以这就是过去影响女性关于举报性骚扰决定的社会证明。另一位年轻女性说她在1994年遇到了Israel Horowitz。Yana Misteki在巴黎的一家小剧院实习，Israel在那里工作。她说他试图亲吻她，有一次，试图把她拉进他的卧室。当Yana发现Bill Marx的故事时，她收到了关于会发生什么的社会证明，
if she spoke out. I had case-based evidence from a 93 article that came out that nothing happened. To Israel Horvitz or the company or the board or anybody else who was responsible for enabling and protecting that behavior. I knew that you put yourself out there and there will be nothing done other than you lose your job and you leave and you're bullied out
如果她大声说出来。我有来自93年发表的文章的案例证据，什么也没发生。对Israel Horowitz或公司或董事会或任何其他负责促成和保护这种行为的人。我知道你把自己置于那种境地，除了你失去工作，你离开，你被欺负出局，什么也不会做。
of it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We're talking this hour about why the Me Two Revolution has caught fire at this particular moment, even though both men and women have known about sexual harassment and assault for decades. We've seen how women were silenced and why it made sense for them to stay quiet. But the science of social norms and preference falsification also explains how a code of silence can abruptly crumble. Again, this story includes descriptions of sexual assault and may not be appropriate for
你正在收听Hidden Brain。这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。我们这一小时在谈论为什么Me Too革命在这一特定时刻爆发，尽管男人和女人几十年来都知道性骚扰和性侵犯。我们已经看到了女性是如何被噤声的，以及为什么她们保持安静是有道理的。但社会规范和偏好伪装的科学也解释了沉默准则如何突然崩溃。再次声明，这个故事包含性侵犯的描述，可能不适合
all listeners. The same year that Yana Mastaki decided to remain quiet, Maya or Mansons was born at St. Vincent's Hospital across the street from Israel Horowitz's brownstone in Grenish village. From an early age, she was drawn to the stage. She started out dancing. It was Maya's dance teacher who recommended her for a role in one of Israel's horror vets' plays. She was 11 years old. Everything about the theater and the playwright delighted her.
所有听众。Yana Mastaki决定保持沉默的那一年，Maya Armanson出生在圣文森特医院，就在Israel Horowitz位于格林威治村的褐砂石建筑对面。从很小的时候起，她就被舞台吸引了。她从跳舞开始。是Maya的舞蹈老师推荐她出演Israel Horowitz的一部戏。她当时11岁。关于剧院和剧作家的一切都让她感到高兴。
Oh, I loved him. He was great. Yeah, it's so much fun with him. He was like a grandfather to me. There was a running thing going on during the production if anyone cursed in front of me. They had to buy me a Toblerone bar, so I got lots of chocolate off of him. Maya stayed close with Israel after the production. He made her feel special. Well, he's just always really kind. He always responded to emails extremely quickly. Yeah, it was just this general sense of feeling that I wasn't just anybody else, that I was valued and respected.
哦，我爱他。他很棒。是的，和他在一起很有趣。他对我来说就像祖父一样。在制作过程中有一件持续的事情，如果有人在我面前咒骂。他们必须给我买一块Toblerone巧克力棒，所以我从他那里得到了很多巧克力。Maya在制作结束后与Israel保持密切联系。他让她感到特别。嗯，他总是非常友善。他总是非常迅速地回复电子邮件。是的，这只是一种普遍的感觉，我觉得我不只是别人，我是被重视和尊重的。
He wrote me recommendations for things. He gave me monologues for auditions. He was great. He came to, at my request, was the speaker at graduation from my middle school at PPA-S, the professional performing arts school. Fast forward a decade. In 2016, when Maya was 21, she was going through a rough time and feeling lost. My cousin had died. My cat had died. I was going through a relationship problems.
他为我写推荐信。他给我独白去试镜。他很棒。他应我的要求，是我初中毕业典礼的演讲者，PPA-S，专业表演艺术学校。快进十年。2016年，当Maya 21岁时，她经历了一段艰难的时期，感到迷茫。我的表弟去世了。我的猫去世了。我正在经历人际关系问题。
It was this world of things that were just getting very difficult to know how to deal with. One day Maya ran into Israel at a reading of one of his plays. She told him what was going on in her life. And he said to me, don't worry, I'm going to give you as many of my short plays as you want and you're going to produce them and that's going to be your project. That's what's going to focus you. And it was really incredible. I thought that it was a beautiful offer, a very cool offer. I'd never produced anything before. He was willing to help me, so it was really meaningful.
这是一堆事情，变得非常难以处理。一天，Maya在Israel的一部戏的朗读会上遇到了他。她告诉他她生活中发生的事情。他对我说，别担心，我会给你尽可能多的短剧，你会制作它们，那将是你的项目。那会让你专注。这真的很不可思议。我认为这是一个美丽的提议，一个非常酷的提议。我以前从未制作过任何东西。他愿意帮助我，所以这真的很有意义。
Maya considered it carefully. She had to conquer her own doubts about whether she was up to it, whether she could direct others, not just be directed. She decided she could. So I emailed him and I said that it would be great. And with a minute I got a response with the attachments to a ton of his plays and so I began sifting through them to see which ones I wanted to do. Maya eventually chose five plays to work on. She recruited an actor who was also interested in producing and they got to work. They changed language that felt dated. They started working on casting. Maya wanted to get as much done as possible so that when she met with Israel,
Maya仔细考虑了它。她必须克服自己关于她是否能胜任的怀疑，她是否能指导别人，而不仅仅是被指导。她决定她可以。所以我给他发了电子邮件，我说那会很棒。一分钟内我就收到了回复，附带了他大量剧作的附件，所以我开始筛选它们，看看我想做哪些。Maya最终选择了五部戏来工作。她招募了一位也对制作感兴趣的演员，他们开始工作。他们修改了感觉过时的语言。他们开始选角。Maya想尽可能多地完成工作，以便当她见到Israel时，
I could show him that I was actually invested in this and that I was putting the time in and I wasn't just waiting for him to tell me what to do. Finally, Maya was ready. She wanted to talk production with Israel. At the time, he was overseeing rehearsals at a theater in downtown Manhattan. He lives just a few blocks away from that theater and I live further uptown.
我可以向他展示我确实投入了其中，我投入了时间，我不是在等他告诉我该做什么。终于，Maya准备好了。她想和Israel谈谈制作。当时，他正在曼哈顿市中心的一家剧院监督排练。他住在离那个剧院只有几个街区的地方，而我住在更北边。
So I was saying I could go downtown to meet him. It's not a problem. And he insisted on coming up to my house. He showed up a half hour earlier than they'd arranged. That threw me off a little bit. But when she met him in the lobby, everything seemed fine. Very friendly, it was very nice. They went in to her apartment. And then the second the door closed behind him. He's just, it was like a switch had flipped. He came and tried to kiss me and then he put his hands on my breasts. And he pulled me to the couch in the living room and had me sit on his lap.
所以我说我可以去市中心见他。没问题。他坚持要来我家。他比约定的时间早到了半小时。这让我有点不知所措。但当她在大厅见到他时，一切似乎都很好。非常友好，非常好。他们进了她的公寓。然后在他身后门关上的那一秒。他就像，就像开关被拨动了一样。他过来试图亲吻我，然后他把手放在我的乳房上。他把我拉到客厅的沙发上，让我坐在他的腿上。
And then I got up and then he pulled me down again back onto his lap. And he stuck his tongue in my mouth and I jerked away. Then he did it again, he held my head in place. And then I tried to get up again. And it was just sort of going around in circles like that. Maya grew up in New York and she thought of herself as tough. But in that moment, she didn't respond the way she would have expected. I felt very self-conscious and nervous of offending him,
然后我站起来，他又把我拉回他的腿上。他把舌头伸进我的嘴里，我猛地挣脱了。然后他又做了一次，他固定住我的头。然后我试图再次站起来。事情就这样绕着圈子进行。Maya在纽约长大，她认为自己很坚强。但在那一刻，她没有做出她预期的反应。我感到非常自我意识和害怕冒犯他，
which is something to this day, I can't believe that that's how I felt in the moment. But then I kept sort of trying to veer the conversation back to the play, back to the work, back to the production. And he interrupted me and he said, before we get started, I just have to say, I've known you since you were so young and your breasts have just become so big and beautiful. And it was just impossible to process what was happening that he was talking to me that way. And it was very strange that he acknowledged in the moment how long he's known me.
这是直到今天，我都不敢相信我在那一刻竟然会有这种感觉。但我一直试图把谈话转回到戏上，转回到工作上，转回到制作上。他打断我说，在我们开始之前，我只想说，我从你很小的时候就认识你了，你的乳房变得如此巨大而美丽。处理正在发生的事情是不可能的，他竟然那样对我说话。而且很奇怪的是，他在那一刻承认了他认识我多久了。
Part of me was almost hoping he's approaching 80, senile maybe doesn't quite understand who I am, but in that sentence, in that line, that clearly wasn't the case. Maya tried again to explain her ideas for the plays. He had no interest in what I had to say about them, he sort of had his game plan for how they should be done. And then she says he tried to kiss her again. And I said I have a boyfriend and he said so I have a wife. And then he said, I'm doing this for you Maya. You know I'm doing this for you because I love you.
我的一部分几乎希望他快80岁了，可能老年痴呆了，不太明白我是谁，但在那句话里，在那一行里，显然不是那样。Maya再次试图解释她对这些戏的想法。他对我要说的话毫无兴趣，他有他自己的游戏计划，关于它们应该如何完成。然后她说他再次试图亲吻她。我说我有男朋友，他说那又怎样，我有妻子。然后他说，我这样做是为了你，Maya。你知道我这样做是为了你，因为我爱你。
I love you. Do you know how much I love you? Do you love me? And you need it to hear me say that I loved him back. And then he told me no great woman ever became great by being a good girl. Maya says she kept resisting. Eventually Israel left. When the door closed behind him and he left, what was going through your head? I punched the kitchen wall and I sat down on the floor and I was just shaking with rage.
我爱你。你知道我有多爱你吗？你爱我吗？你需要听到我说我也爱你。然后他告诉我，没有伟大的女性是通过做乖乖女而变得伟大的。Maya说她一直在反抗。最终Israel离开了。当门在他身后关上，他离开时，你脑子里在想什么？我打了厨房的墙，我坐在地板上，我因为愤怒而颤抖。
The rage that wasn't there when he was in the apartment. It was all very, I almost felt like my 11 year old self dealing with him when we were face to face. And the second I didn't see him anymore, the second I got him out of the apartment, I just couldn't believe I had just let him leave and hadn't hit him. It was a very, very strange sad moment. For more than 25 years,
那种愤怒在他还在公寓里时并不存在。这一切都非常……我几乎觉得当我们在面对面时，是我11岁的自己在处理他。而我再也看不到他的那一秒，我把他赶出公寓的那一秒，我简直不敢相信我竟然让他离开了，而没有打他。那是一个非常、非常奇怪、悲伤的时刻。超过25年来，
Israel Horowitz was protected by silence. Women who tried to speak up were shut down. The Whisper Network had turned thready and faint. Maya did not know about the accusations in Israel's past. But after the incident, she called her friends. She told her mother, who quickly tracked down the articles from the Boston Phoenix. And reading those articles changed something in me.
以色列·霍洛维茨受到沉默的保护。试图发声的女性被压制了。耳语网络变得微弱而模糊。玛雅并不知道以色列过去被指控的事情。但在那次事件后，她给朋友们打了电话。她告诉了她的母亲，母亲很快找到了《波士顿凤凰报》的相关文章。阅读这些文章改变了我内心的一些东西。
The description of what he did to them was exactly what he did to me. Maya wanted people to know what had happened. She called a prominent theater where Israel often worked. She says the director didn't call back. It was radio silence for three months. And then one day I saw on Instagram actually a post of Israel in rehearsal on stage for the play they were working on. And it was captioned, the man at work with a bunch of hashtags like genius, love, the
关于他对她们所作所为的描述，和我经历的一模一样。玛雅想让人们知道发生了什么。她给以色列经常工作的一家著名剧院打了电话。她说导演没有回电。三个月来一直杳无音信。然后有一天，我在Instagram上看到了一张以色列在舞台上排练他们正在制作的剧目的照片。标题写着：正在工作的男人，还带了一堆标签，比如天才、爱、
theater. Maya burned with a white heart fury. I got so live it. I got so livid. I couldn't believe it. So she sat at her kitchen table and slammed out a post on Facebook. I asked her to read it for us. In the beginning of June, I had a meeting with the playwright in my home. He is my senior by several decades.
剧院。玛雅怒火中烧。我变得非常愤怒。我变得非常愤怒。我简直不敢相信。于是她坐在厨房的桌子旁，在Facebook上猛烈地写下了一篇帖子。我请她为我们读一下。六月初，我和那位剧作家在我家开了一个会。他比我年长几十岁。
I've known him since I was 11. I regarded him as an honorary grandfather. Maya described in detail what Israel had done to her, but did not mention his name. She finished up the post this way. And it hurts me that even though some people do know what he's done, it doesn't seem to matter. And there will be more women.
我从11岁起就认识他了。我一直把他当作一位名誉祖父。玛雅详细描述了以色列对她所做的事情，但没有提到他的名字。她在帖子的结尾这样写道：让我感到痛苦的是，尽管有些人知道他做了什么，但这似乎并不重要。而且还会有更多的女性受害者。
And some of them may be a lot tougher than me, but some of them will surely be a lot less tough. We've got to protect each other, especially when it would be so easy for a woman to feel this was her fault. That might have been where the story ended, but then, news broke. A tape surfaced in which then presidential candidate Donald Trump bragged about assaulting women. I'm going to use some text just in case I start kissing her. You know, I'm automatically attracted to beautiful. I just start kissing them. It's like a magnet. It was the infamous Axis Hollywood tape.
其中一些人可能比我坚强得多，但肯定也会有一些人没那么坚强。我们必须互相保护，尤其是在女性很容易觉得这是自己错的情况下。故事本可能到此为止，但随后，新闻爆发了。一段录音浮出水面，当时还是总统候选人的唐纳德·特朗普吹嘘自己侵犯女性。我得用点润滑剂，以防我开始亲吻她。你知道，我会被美女自动吸引。我直接就开始亲吻她们。就像磁铁一样。这就是臭名昭著的《走进好莱坞》录音带。
And when you're a star, they let you do it. You can do anything. Whatever you want. Grab them by the ****. I can do anything. Just the casual nature of it is They have they they Yeah, it's he just you know he can grab women's Bodies Israel grabbed my body. It wasn't mine
当你是个明星时，她们会让你这么做。你可以做任何事。随心所欲。抓住她们的私处。我可以做任何事。那种随意的态度就是……她们有……她们……是的，他只是……你知道，他可以抓住女性的身体。以色列抓住了我的身体。那不是我的。
They didn't see he didn't see it as mine Trump doesn't see it as the woman's body like it's theirs they have some ownership over it. And that really, really upset me. It still upsets me. Maya watched in disbelief as Donald Trump was elected president. I've just received a call from Secretary Clinton. She can graduated us. It's about us on our victory.
她们没有看到……他没有把它看作是我的。特朗普并不认为那是女性的身体，就像那是她们的一样，他们对它拥有某种所有权。这真的、真的让我很不安。现在依然让我不安。玛雅难以置信地看着唐纳德·特朗普当选总统。我刚刚接到了克林顿国务卿的电话。她祝贺我们。这是关于我们，关于我们的胜利。
At that moment, something snapped. The day after Trump's election, Maya reopened her Facebook post. I reposted the original thing at the original piece that I wrote, and I just put something at the top saying that in the late of the election, I'm ready to say the name. It was the playwright, Israel Horowitz. Maya also felt compelled to find other women who'd been through what she had been through. She had powerful tools at her disposal. Facebook, Twitter, Google. It was a whisper network, but on high octane.
那一刻，有什么东西断了。特朗普当选后的第二天，玛雅重新打开了她的Facebook帖子。我重新发布了最初的那篇我写的文章，并在顶部加了一句话，说在选举之后，我准备说出那个名字。那就是剧作家，以色列·霍洛维茨。玛雅还感到有必要找到其他经历过她所经历之事的女性。她拥有强大的工具：Facebook、Twitter、谷歌。这是一个耳语网络，但动力十足。
One of the first people she connected with was Yana Mastecchi, who had states silent about what happened after she met Israel and Paris in 1994. When she heard Maya's story, Yana knew she had to speak up too. It made me mad that it was still happening and that maybe if I had said something, maybe it would make a difference. I don't know that it would have made a difference then, but I'm raising two girls and, you know, I couldn't look at myself if I didn't. Maya also did something else.
她联系上的第一批人之一是亚娜·马斯特基，她在1994年于巴黎遇见以色列后，一直对发生的事情保持沉默。当她听到玛雅的故事时，亚娜知道她也必须站出来。这让我很生气，因为这种事还在发生，也许如果我当时说了什么，可能会有所不同。我不知道当时是否会有所不同，但我正在抚养两个女儿，你知道，如果我不这样做，我就无法面对自己。玛雅还做了另一件事。
She contacted the New York Times. All over the country, powerful men were being toppled on charges of sexual harassment. In late November 2017, the Times published an article detailing the stories of nine women who publicly accused Israel Horowitz of harassment and abuse. In that article, the playwright apologized, but said he had a different memory of some of these events. The reaction to this article was completely different than in 1993. The Gloucester Stage Company quickly severed ties with Israel, other companies cancelled productions of his
她联系了《纽约时报》。在全国各地，有权势的男性因性骚扰指控而纷纷倒台。2017年11月下旬，《纽约时报》发表了一篇文章，详细叙述了九名女性公开指控以色列·霍洛维茨骚扰和虐待的故事。在那篇文章中，这位剧作家道歉了，但表示他对其中一些事件有不同的记忆。对这篇文章的反应与1993年完全不同。格洛斯特舞台剧团迅速切断了与以色列的关系，其他公司也取消了他作品的制作。
plays. His own son, Adam Horowitz, said he believed the accusations. Not long ago, I was talking to my wife over dinner about this story. I was trying to understand why now? Why are women being heard in a way they were not heard before? My wife, Ashwini Thambe, researchers gender issues and recently wrote about this topic. I'm an associate professor of women studies at the University of Maryland College Park. What she told me about was a theory of horizontal violence. Horizontal violence is when people turn on other people
他的儿子亚当·霍洛维茨说他相信这些指控。不久前，我和妻子在晚餐时谈到了这个故事。我试图理解为什么是现在？为什么女性现在能以以前无法被倾听的方式被倾听？我的妻子阿什维尼·坦贝研究性别问题，最近写过这个话题。我是马里兰大学帕克分校妇女研究系的副教授。她告诉我的关于水平暴力的理论。水平暴力是指当人们无法对更强大的目标产生实际影响时，就会转向攻击自己生活中的其他人。
in their own lives when they are not able to actually effect change against more powerful targets. It's a term used by the 20th century psychiatrist and philosopher, Franz Fanon. He wrote about how people living on the brutal colonial rule dealt with oppression. Because it's so difficult to attack or target colonial rulers, what Fanon found was that people were lashing against people in their own lives. Think about pressure building up in a container. The energy needs a way to escape. If it can't blow the top off, it might explode sideways.
这是一个由20世纪精神病学家和哲学家弗朗茨·法农使用的术语。他写了关于生活在残酷殖民统治下的人们如何应对压迫的文章。因为攻击或针对殖民统治者太困难了，法农发现人们在攻击自己生活中的人。想想容器中积聚的压力。能量需要一个逃逸的出口。如果它不能掀开盖子，它可能会向侧面爆炸。
I think that the election of Donald Trump has served as a trigger and it has provoked a great deal of fury and impatience because he represents for many people the ultimate unpunished predator. Fanor used the term horizontal violence to describe rage that was misdirected or misplaced. Ashwini says horizontal action is a better term to describe how many women have channeled their rage over Trump's election to call out the men
我认为唐纳德·特朗普的当选起到了触发作用，它激起了极大的愤怒和不耐烦，因为对于许多人来说，他代表了最终未受惩罚的掠夺者。法农使用水平暴力一词来描述被误导或错位的愤怒。阿什维尼说，水平行动是一个更好的术语，用来描述许多女性如何引导她们对特朗普当选的愤怒，去揭露那些性骚扰她们的男性。
in their own lives who sexually harass them. It feels very, very important in this moment to topple those perpetrators who are within reach because at this moment Trump remains unreachable even though Trump shapes the context in which enormous anger against misogyny and sexual harassment has risen. Maya has the same take as Ashwin. I think it's Trump. I think that's what it is. Clearly, there's been something building for a long time, but it's such a huge deal for
在这一刻，推翻那些触手可及的施暴者感觉非常、非常重要，因为在这一刻，特朗普仍然遥不可及，尽管特朗普塑造了针对厌女症和性骚扰的巨大愤怒升起的背景。玛雅和阿什维尼有同样的看法。我认为是特朗普。我想就是这样。显然，有些东西已经积压了很长时间，但对于你的领导人，自由世界的领导人来说，不关心女性，这太不可思议了。
your leader, the leader of the free world, to not care about women, that it's so unbelievable. Laura Croque was one of the women who came forward to speak to the press in 1993. She did so again in 2017. She's grateful that her allegations were taken seriously this time around. But when she thinks about what happened to Maya, she can't get over the terrible cost of the delay. I just wish I wish I could have stopped it in 93. It breaks my heart. It breaks my heart. But so many women had to go through this when it's...
劳拉·克罗克是1993年站出来向媒体讲述的女性之一。她在2017年再次这样做。她很感激这次她的指控被认真对待了。但当她想到玛雅身上发生的事情时，她无法释怀延迟带来的可怕代价。我只是希望……我希望我能在93年阻止它。这让我心碎。这让我心碎。但这么多女性不得不经历这些，而这……
was... stoppable. It was absolutely stoppable. Shortly before the fall of the Berlin Wall, experts on both sides of the Atlantic was certain that the Soviet Union would endure for many decades. Preference falsification blinded regimes to their citizens growing dissatisfaction. The pressure reached a breaking point in 1989. It took authorities by surprise. As protests at the Berlin Wall gained momentum, the regime that once looked invincible suddenly looked fragile. Preference falsification now started to work in the other direction.
是……可以阻止的。它绝对是可以阻止的。在柏林墙倒塌前不久，大西洋两岸的专家都确信苏联将持续几十年。偏好伪装使政权对公民日益增长的不满视而不见。压力在1989年达到了临界点。这让当局措手不及。随着柏林墙抗议活动的势头增强，那个曾经看起来不可战胜的政权突然显得脆弱不堪。偏好伪装现在开始向相反的方向起作用。
Very quickly, defending the old regime became dangerous. In exactly the same way, many powerful, many accused of sexual assault have found themselves without defenders, even amongst their own families. The social proof has changed. In Israel's play, the widow's blind date, Margi goes back home 20 years after she was gang raped. She wants to confront her assailants, to hear them say they did something wrong. Twenty years after what she describes as the worst summer of her life, Jocelyn Minehart, the playwriting fellow who worked on that play in 1989, made an appointment to meet with
很快，捍卫旧政权变得危险起来。以完全相同的方式，许多有权势的、许多被指控性侵的人发现自己失去了捍卫者，即使是在他们自己的家庭中。社会证明已经改变了。在以色列的剧作《寡妇的盲约》中，玛吉在被轮奸20年后回到了家。她想面对她的施暴者，听他们说他们做错了事。在描述了她一生中最糟糕的夏天20年后，1989年参与该剧创作的剧作研究员乔斯林·米恩哈特预约了与
Israel. He was just like, oh, it's so great to see you. We should have gotten together a lot. It's been too long. But then when we sat down for coffee, I just said, you know, the reason I have a reason for seeing you and I just want to talk about what happened. And I didn't say rape. I think I, you know, I said, I talked about the trauma. I was like, that was deeply traumatic. It affected my whole life, and it's affected my romantic relationships, my relationships, you know, just everything.
以色列见面。他就像，哦，见到你真是太好了。我们应该多聚聚的。太久没见了。但当我们坐下来喝咖啡时，我只是说，你知道，我见你是有原因的，我只是想谈谈发生的事情。我没有说强奸。我想我，你知道，我说了，我谈到了创伤。我说，那是非常痛苦的。它影响了我的一生，影响了我的浪漫关系，我的关系，你知道，就是一切。
And he was like, what? You know, just sort of taking it back. Jocelyn says Israel apologized. But in that non-apologetic way, when, you know, it's not, it wasn't anything that landed and that he took really took responsibility for it. She says he suggested that what happened between them was not abusive. At one point he was just like do you remember us like as if it was a romantic thing that I was just remembering wrong which was
他说，什么？你知道，只是有点吃惊。乔斯林说以色列道歉了。但那种非道歉的方式，你知道，那根本没有触及重点，他也没有真正为此承担责任。她说他暗示他们之间发生的事情并非虐待。有一次他只是说，你还记得我们吗？好像那是一件浪漫的事情，是我记错了，这真是
in raging and and the thing that really really sticks with me and really also was angering. I was just that You know you weren't underaged like because it wasn't because I was 19 That made it okay Not long after Maya named Israel in her Facebook post she received a voicemail Maya, this is Israel calling. I'm so upset. I don't know what to say. I had no idea.
令人愤怒，而真正让我耿耿于怀、也让我非常愤怒的事情是，你知道，你当时不是未成年，因为不是因为我19岁，所以那才没关系。玛雅在Facebook帖子中点名以色列后不久，她收到了一条语音留言：玛雅，我是以色列。我太难过了。我不知道该说什么。我根本不知道。
It's a terrible, terrible misunderstanding. It was a terrible, mixed signal. And I didn't know you were upset. And I love you, Maya Maya and I never, never would hurt you that way. Never, never, never. Please, you've got to believe me. Oh my God, I'm just shaking. Somebody just wrote to me and told me about it. I don't know what to say. I'm so sorry and I love you and I would never, never, never hurt you that way. That was such a missing on such a... oh my god.
这是一个可怕的、可怕的误解。这是一个可怕的、错误的信号。我不知道你很难过。我爱你，玛雅，我永远、永远不会那样伤害你。永远，永远，永远。求你，你一定要相信我。天哪，我浑身发抖。有人刚写信告诉我这件事。我不知道该说什么。我太抱歉了，我爱你，我永远、永远、永远不会那样伤害你。那真是一个……天哪。
It is not to us. Israel said the widow's blind date quote states clearly my feeling about sexual violence against women which I find to be be a boring and intolerable. We asked actors to read some lines from the end of Israel's play. In the scene, one of the men who raped Margi tries to explain why he did it. Nobody planned it, Margi. It just happened.
这不属于我们。以色列说《寡妇的盲约》引用的话清楚地说明了我对针对女性的性暴力的感受，我觉得这是令人厌恶和无法容忍的。我们请演员朗读了以色列剧作结尾的一些台词。在这一幕中，其中一个强奸玛吉的男人试图解释他为什么这样做。没人计划过，玛吉。这只是发生了。
Honest to God. I mean, well, boys are always talking about wanting to do it with this one or that one and Everybody was always saying they'd love to do it with you because you were well Beautiful But nobody really mented Jumping yeah, it's just when George here. Well started everybody wanted to It's just when George here, well, started. Everybody wanted to, to everybody liked you.
老天作证。我是说，嗯，男孩们总是谈论想和这个或那个做那件事，每个人总是说他们很想和你做，因为你很……漂亮。但没人真的打算……跳起来，是的，只是当乔治在这里时。嗯，每个人都想……只是当乔治在这里时，嗯，开始了。每个人都想，每个人都喜欢你。
You liked me, Arch? I did, a lot. And that's how you showed me you liked me. I was tricked out of first I was. Otherwise, Marky, the first word you would have heard whispered in your ear would have been, I love you. Because I did. And I do.
你喜欢我，阿奇？我喜欢，非常喜欢。这就是你向我展示你喜欢我的方式。我被骗了，起初我是。否则，玛吉，你耳边听到的第一个词应该是，我爱你。因为我爱过。而且我依然爱着。
I do still mock something wicked. I love you would not have helped. Since this episode first aired, several more women have publicly come forward to accuse Israel Horowitz of sexual misconduct. We reached out to him, but he declined to speak with us. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman and Path Shah and edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Thomas Liu and Laura Quarral. Our intern is Camilla Varga's Restrepo. We had original music today from Ramteen Arableui.
我依然……有些邪恶。我爱你那句话不会有帮助。自本集首次播出以来，又有几名女性公开站出来指控以色列·霍洛维茨行为不端。我们联系了他，但他拒绝与我们交谈。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼和帕斯·沙制作，由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸拉尔。我们的实习生是卡米拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。我们今天的原创音乐来自拉姆廷·阿拉布伊。
Laura C. Harris and Ericner, performed the scenes from the Widows blind date. Special thanks to Patrice Howard, Ashley Messinger, Greg Lewis, Chris Turpin, Neil Karuth, Mark Mammoth and Anja Grunman. This week's unsung hero is Tarana Burke. In 1997, 20 years before the Me Too hashtag led up social media, Toronto Berks started a movement to help victims of sexual harassment and assault. She called it Me Too. While millions of people now know about this hashtag, far fewer know about the woman who created the term. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉·C·哈里斯和埃里克纳表演了《寡妇的盲约》中的场景。特别感谢帕特里斯·霍华德、阿什利·梅辛格、格雷格·刘易斯、克里斯·特平、尼尔·卡鲁斯、马克·马莫斯和安雅·格伦曼。本周的无名英雄是塔拉纳·伯克。1997年，在“我也是”（Me Too）标签席卷社交媒体的20年前，塔拉纳·伯克发起了一项运动，旨在帮助性骚扰和性侵犯的受害者。她称之为“我也是”。虽然现在有数百万人知道这个标签，但知道这位创造该术语的女性的人却少得多。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。